فيما يتعلق بتقييم الانظمه حتى في الغرب
هو النتائج التي تحققها على المستوى
الاقتصادي وعلى المستوى الاجتماعي هناك
مؤشرات فيما يتعلق مثلا سنه
2021 كالكشف المعهد البريطاني
عن تصنيف الدول على المستوى الرخاء
والازدهار في المنطقه العربيه
وتصدرت التمارين الدول الملكيه الترتيب
ولم تكن اي دوله تعتمد نظام الجمهوري ضمن
هذه الدول الثمانيه ايضا في مؤشر
اخر يتعلق
بالامان والعيش في امان بالنسبه للدول
العربيه سنه
تصدر الترتيب ثمانيه دول الثمانيه الدول
الملكيه ايضا ترتيب الدول في مؤشر الصحه
خاصه الفتره بين اغسطس 2020
واكتوبر 2021 كان عز ازمه كورونا كانت
الانظمه
الملكيه ثماني الدول هي التي تتصدر
الترتيب بالنسبه الى مستوى العيش يعني
المدن التي يكون فيها العيش
تتوفر فيها كل ظروف العيش كان هناك تقرير
لاورونيوس صدر سنه 1922 كانت من بين 14
عاصمه 14 مدينه كانت مدينه تونس فقط من
خارج المدن الموجوده في يعني في الدول
التي يسدها النظام الملكي هذه مؤشرات هذه
المؤشرات حيه وهذه ارقام حقيقيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن لا يمكن الحديث عن عن عن
نتائج في صحيح انه في فترات كانت هناك
نتائج مهمه في عدد من الدول التي يسودها
النظام الجمهوري ولكن كما قلت بانه هذه
الانظمه على مر التاريخ لا ايضا لم يتحقق
فيها الاستقرار لان الاستقرار عامل اساسي
تحدث ضيفنا العزيز حول الصين الاستقرار
عامل اساسي فيما يتعلق بالنجاح الاقتصاديه
وايضا فيما يتعلق بالحكامه وفيما يتعلق
بالقدره على اتخاذ القرار وعلى تنفيذه
اليوم مثلا سوريا عند ابن سوريا لاقدم
جمهوريه
العربيه يعني يمكن الحديث منذ 1932
يعني لما تعود الى التاريخ لا سواء
بالنسبه لسوريا او بالنسبه للعراق او لا
بالنسبه مسلسل من الانقلابات
يعني داخل نفس بنيه النظام وهذا الامر
بطبيعه الحال اثر على القدره على بناء
التراكمات على مستوى الدوله والتراكم بل
كانت هناك انظمه تذهب وتجيء ولكن
لم يتحقق من تراكم للاسف